DON OLMSTEAD: So,
as Tony mentioned,
my name is Don Olmstead.
I work over at Sony
Network Entertainment,
and I wrote the WebGL
layer for the PS4.
So, obviously, thank
you all for coming.
And really, it's been an amazing
response with everything.
And definitely
excited to be here.
So Tony gave sort of the grand
overview of what is WebGL.
The next speakers
are probably going
to give a bunch of
fun, cool demos.
And I'm here to blind you
with computer science.
So, I'm definitely not going
to give you any fun whiz
bang demos or
anything like that,
but afterwards,
you're going to have
a much better understanding
on how WebGL actually
works under the hood.
And the reality
is that, yeah, you
might be using a
framework like three
or any other of the
many frameworks,
but there's a good chance
that if you're really,
really pushing the
hardware, eventually
you're going to outgrow it.
And then you're going to need
to come down to my level here.
So, I wanted to
start off with what
I did for the PS4 and some
of the choices we made here.
So, let's talk about the PS4.
We released in November,
the same day this meet-up
was announced.
And actually we sold a
million units in a single day.
And sales continued to be pretty
good, 4.2 million in 2013.
And obviously, the best
part is that every time you
log in you are
running WebGL code.
So, why did we end
up using WebGL?
Well, to be honest, it
was really more or less
a pragmatic decision.
So here I'm going
to talk a little bit
about the architecture
of the PlayStation store,
which is what our team works on.
So, we really
wanted the same code
to run on multiple platforms.
And obviously, the most
important avenue for this
is PlayStation hardware itself.
So this is the PS3 and the PS4.
But, we also wanted to support
people working in the browser.
And this is just to
make devs' lives easier,
in case they were away
from their hardware,
and really, that's where
the WebGL usage started.
So, actually, most of
our devs use Chrome,
and if you went to
our booth outside,
you could actually
see the PlayStation
store running in Chrome.
And that was more
or less what we had.
So in this case,
I wanted to start
by giving more of an overview
of what it is we actually have.
What does our software
stack look like.
So, in the case of the PS3, the
bottom is actually PhyreEngine.
And PhyreEnginer
is a game engine
provided by Sony
for all licensees.
And, actually, it
powered Journey.
So same set of code there.
On top of that, we had an API
layer we called TriLithium.
So, this is actually
a JavaScript API
for drawing a 2D scene.
I was not involved
in the naming.
So, actually, this is all
bound to a JavaScript VM,
and it allowed our programmers
to create this UI layer, which
is more or less a home-grown,
immediate-mode GUI, made
to look DOM-ish.
And on top of that, our devs ran
and made the PlayStation store.
So let's talk about the PS4.
So obviously, we had
a large codebase,
we needed compatibility
with the PS3,
we also wanted
more web features,
and we didn't have time to
rewrite the whole thing.
So we actually have a
working port of WebKit
that powers our browser.
This is more or less
where I normally work in,
on the rendering side there.
And to actually do the
port, what we needed to do
was recreate that TriLithium
layer, but in WebGL.
So that meant for
us our UI framework
didn't have to change,
and neither did the store.
So we had a problem.
We reached a point where launch
was looming in front of us,
and basically, the
performance was not there.
And really, the user experience
was suffering because of it.
So we started
investigating the issue,
and my assertion was
it's JavaScript's fault.
So, for me, the
avenue to go would
be to attract attack that
bottom TriLithium layer
and fix it, essentially.
So, I started
optimizing this layer,
but I really wasn't getting
the performance gains
I actually wanted, and what I
thought was actually possible.
So, we're really
close to launch,
performance isn't there,
so what do you do?
Well as a seasoned
developer knows,
you burn everything
to the ground.
And in its place, create
something awesome.
So, really I only recommend
that as a last resort,
and I more or less
went down this route
because I was already touching
a good amount of the code,
and I really wanted to open
up all the optimizations
that really I'm here
to talk to you about.
So, with the intro, let's begin.
So what do you need to know?
Well, first off,
if you're actually
trying to figure out what's
going with your WebGL
application, you
want to profile.
So you need to
profile and figure out
exactly where your app
is spending its time.
And if rendering turns
out to be a problem,
and you're using
WebGL, you really
need to understand two things.
So that's how does WebGL
slot into the browser?
You need to know how WebGL
works so you can optimize
your interaction with the API.
So then, you walk
further up the stack.
You need to start thinking about
how you're submitting geometry.
And of course,
you need to ensure
that work is being
done completely
in the animation loop itself.
All right, so first off, let's
talk about animation frame.
So you basically have
16.6 milliseconds
to do all your work.
And honestly, it's safer if you
finish quite a bit before then.
So, if you finish in
the allotted time,
you'll get, of course,
the silky smooth 60 FPS,
the holy grail of all
graphics programming.
And if you don't do it,
you're going to drop a frame.
And if you do it enough,
your user experience
will definitely suffer.
The animations themselves
will look jerky,
the controls will seem laggy.
It's not good.
And this was more or less the
state we were in beforehand.
So the other thing to
remember is, on top of that,
the browser is doing
plenty of other things
that can further
limit your frame time.
So, the big one of course, is
the waste monster, also known
as the garbage collector.
And you have to remember,
it can trigger at any time
and take as much
time as it wants.
It doesn't care.
So, you also need to know that
other browser events are going
to happen outside of
the animation frame.
And this is something we're
going to circle back to later
on.
So when you're
profiling, we need
to look at what
happens during a frame.
And we use a profiler.
There are actually two types
available to the web dev,
in Chrome specifically.
So you have that
sampling profiler,
and this will essentially
take little snapshots
to try and determine
where the time is
being spent within your app.
And that's essentially what you
find in the Chrome Developer
Tools.
So, something that's
a bit more advanced
is a structural profiler.
So in this case, you're
actually inserting code
into your code to figure out
where your time's being spent.
And this is something
you'll find if you use
chrome://tracing, and you'll
basically litter your code with
console time, console time end.
But there's an even
better solution,
which is the Web
Tracing Framework.
Unfortunately, the Web Tracing
Framework came out a little bit
after when I would
have really liked it,
but it's a solution from
Google, and obviously,
one of the programmers is
a smart ass because WTF.
So you have your structural
profiler, what do you do?
Where do you begin?
So, really, you want
to place markers
at various points of
interest in your code.
For graphics application,
typically, there's an update,
and then there's a render.
So these are the
sort of things where
you want to place
the markers, and then
continue deep diving
further and further.
And from there, you'll
be able to figure out
what exactly is going on.
So, here's a little slide
with what the Web Tracing
Framework will give you.
If you look here, obviously
really hard to tell,
but over on this side is the
update, over on this side
is the render.
So, this particular
trace, it was
from an example game
on their home page.
And you can see how this
is a lot of information.
And if you're familiar
with chrome://tracing,
you'll see it's presented
in a much nicer way.
With chrome://tracing,
you get everything,
which is a bit harder
to drill down into.
So I definitely recommend
playing with it on your own
and it also does some
other fun things,
like the garbage collection,
so it'll actually tell you
where the garbage
collection's happening.
So, let's say we
ran our application,
and we are seeing a good amount
of time in the render portion.
So what do we do?
It's really important to know
what's going on under the hood.
So in this case, I'm
going to talk about Blink.
And I'm going to talk
about Blink because WebKit
is way more
convoluted than Blink.
So in our app, we're going
to make a WebGL call.
So we're in our JavaScript
code, and from there, the call
goes into the
V8WebGLRenderingContext.
So, basically,
any of the browser
APIs that end up getting
exposed to the application,
they tend to be auto
generated, and there's actually
an interface definition language
that generates all this.
So this is the same thing
with the WebGL base.
So, from there,
we're going to end up
in the WebGLRenderingContext.
And at this point,
we're going to handle
any sort of validation and
any sort of security checks.
So after that, we
can take a detour
to the ContextSupport class.
The naming's not there,
actually, Brandon Jones,
one of the Chrome GPU
developers, was telling me,
no, your diagram's wrong,
here's how it is now.
So there is some sort
of ContextSupport class
that will essentially do
stuff like loading a texture.
But really where
it's going to end up,
is a WebGraphicsContext.
So, the thing to remember
is that WebGL is not
the only thing running
in the browser.
So, there are certain
conditions that
will cause your web page
to be promoted to the GPU.
And web devs typically do this
with a translation of zero.
So any of that,
they're kind of hoping
it's going to promote
it to the graphics card,
and hopefully it's faster.
Now, that WebGraphicsContext,
what it does,
is it fills a command buffer.
And that command buffer
ends up getting picked up
by the GPU process.
So, obviously,
there's a lot of code.
And this is more or less
the 1,000-foot view.
But this kind of
gives you an idea
on what happens every time
you make a call into WebGL.
So what's the takeaway?
Well, every time
you call into WebGL,
there's always going to be
some amount of overhead.
And you're not going
to be able to avoid it.
It's there completely by design,
to ensure security, as well as
support other things the
browser is actually doing.
So what this means is
there's a hard limit
to the number of calls
that can happen in a frame.
Now, the exact number is really
going to vary on the hardware,
but because of this,
we need to make
sure we are making the smallest
possible number of calls
to WebGL.
So, how do we know what
calls should actually occur?
Well, WebGL itself
is a state machine.
So what that means is that
when you make a WebGL call
you are very likely
to be changing state.
There's some calls that
won't change state,
but the good chunk of them, if
you're actually doing any work,
are going to modify
some form of state.
So this could be
multiple things.
So you can affect the entirety
of the rendering context,
so you can do
something like change
the depth test you're using.
And that's going to be when
you change it, it's there,
and that's what's happening.
You can also change the
state of a WebGL object.
WebGL object is
basically anything
you would make through
a create function.
So, this includes stuff like
textures, your shader programs,
and your buffers.
So, if a call that
should change state
does not actually change
any state after execution,
this is known as
a redundant call.
So, in this case, I'm going
to give you an example.
So on the left, we have
just a simple batching code,
it's just going to be
interacting with the program,
saying some uniforms, and
then it's off on its way.
On the right, I'm
giving a diagram on
what's happening in the totality
of the rendering context,
as well as what's happening with
the individual program itself.
So if we step through
this function,
first off, we hit gl.useProgram.
So this is going to bind the
program to the pipeline you're
now rendering with that
particular program.
You're going to call
and modify the uniform.
Now, in this case, we are taking
the alpha within the shader
and we're setting it to 0.5.
That's cool because we
were at zero before.
Now we go ahead and we
modify the texture unit
our sampler is referring to,
and we're setting it to zero.
Well the thing is,
it was already zero,
and essentially, this
call did nothing.
And of course, if
you're doing this,
you're paying the price for
it, as it's a redundant call.
So how do we stop this?
Well this actually requires
some brains in the application.
Basically, if you're writing
a renderer for WebGL,
you basically need to mirror
the entire state of WebGL
within your application.
So, whenever a call is
made, essentially, we
need to compare
the current value
to the value we
want to set it to.
And if it's not equal, we can
go ahead and let the call slide
through.
If it is equal, we want
to stop it in its tracks.
And, like I said,
the renderer needs
to be designed to handle this
for every single instance
of WebGL call to be optimal.
So, in this example, I grab some
of the code from the TriLithium
API, and this is one
of those cases where
we are limiting the
number of calls.
And this is just a simple front
door, it has a current state.
When you try and
set the value, it
compares it to the current
value within the front door.
And like I said,
if it's different,
we go ahead and make the call.
If it's the same, we
ignore it completely.
So really, this was
a big win for us.
The older version of the
API did nothing like this.
So it drastically cut
down the number of calls
and here are some
results for you.
So at best, we're making a
quarter of the number of calls.
That meant that in some cases,
3/4 of the number of calls
were worthless.
And at worst, we seem
to be making about half
the number of calls we made.
And my completely
unscientific study of it
seemed to say that it
was about 1/3 on average.
And really, at
this point in time,
everything started
feeling a lot better.
It was a lot less scary that
I burned everything down.
And people were quite a bit
more receptive at this point.
So, with our optimized renderer
in place, we need to go higher.
Remember, you can still
get yourself in trouble
if you aren't submitting your
geometry in an optimal way.
So, here are some general
rules you should be following.
If you can't see
it, don't drive.
Basically, you want to compare
the geometry to the camera.
If the camera can see it,
go ahead and let it through.
If it can't, stop
it in its tracks.
We also want to submit any
opaque geometry front to back.
Now, the rationale here is
if you have a large geometry,
and it's fairly close
to you, but there's
another geometry behind it,
you draw that one first.
The depth test for that second
geometry is likely a fail.
And if you have a
fragment shader that's
taking up a good amount of time,
that can save you some work,
and it's definitely
optimization you should try for.
But also remember
on the converse,
the opposite is true for
your transparent geometry.
You want to render
them the opposite way.
Otherwise, your blending
will not look correct.
And of course,
what you want to do
is also to try to group
geometry with the same state.
And this is to
minimize the amount
of calls we're
going into web geo.
Of course, the most important
rule of optimization,
optimize for your case,
not the general case.
You really need to think
about how you're scene works,
you need to figure
out your requirements,
and you need to design
your algorithm around this.
And that's how
you will really be
able to push the hardware
in new and interesting ways.
So in this case, what did
the PlayStation store scene
look like?
The tree was pretty deep.
We had a lot of nodes
that were basically
used to position other nodes.
And the worst case I saw
was a tree with 26 levels.
It was a ton of nodes, not a
lot of actual drawable entities.
The other thing to remember,
in the PlayStation store,
was our textures were unique.
So we would constantly be
requesting product images,
text, and that didn't really
allow us to do sheeting.
Texture sheeting
is a technique you
would use to limit the number
of times you switch a texture.
CSS can also do
something like this.
Definitely the perf guys
will tell you to do this.
So, another thing that was a
characteristic of our scene,
was the objects themselves
weren't too mobile.
So that means that really
the only time stuff
would start moving is
when you had user input.
And we also had a
requirement that some areas
needed to be clipped
to some bounding area.
So with that in
mind, what did we do?
So since things weren't
moving that much,
the visible set was only
computed when the tree changed.
So the visible set meaning,
we run through our tree,
we figure out what is
actually available to draw,
and we use that to
feed the renderer.
The scene was deep, so
rather than bubbling up
the bounding volumes,
which is what you'll
see in a lot of engines
where the bounding volume
of the object below
affects the one up higher,
and we bubble up, up, up,
up, all the way to the top.
So, this didn't
really help us, and it
would have created a
hell of a lot more work,
because, as I said,
a lot of the things
have to do with positioning.
And, in our case,
whenever we-- So
we use those bonding volumes as
the actual points of clipping.
And when the intersected
bounding volume was met,
what we would do,
is intersect those,
and use that smaller
bounding volume
to affect the geometry
further down the tree.
So let me give you
an example of that.
So, let's say that in the
case of the yellowish nodes,
those actually have clipping
volumes associated with them.
So, we work our
way down the left
and we compare those
two clipping volumes.
We do an intersection.
They do intersect,
so then we use
that smaller volume to
compare the leaf node.
In this case, it passes, so
it's added to the visible side.
So then we're going to continue
down over on this side,
and we just compare
it with that top one.
And we find it's within our
view, so it goes through.
Now we go further down
into the right side.
So we're comparing these two
and seeing the intersection.
So there's actually no
intersection, so at that point,
we can say, all
right, we're not even
going to bother with
the rest of you guys.
So, that's more or less how the
algorithm worked in our case.
So, the last tip for
you is to keep your work
within the animation frame.
So, as I mentioned,
the browser has
a ton of other things going on.
It does not think
you're that important.
So, there are things
that are going
to happen outside of your frame.
The big one there would
obviously be timeouts.
And it also includes
getting your images,
getting your HTTP
requests, and of course,
remember, if there's an event
or series of events that take up
a good amount of your time, you
can completely drop a frame,
and you will be
looking at your frame
and say, well, I was ready
in five milliseconds.
I don't know what happened.
Well, most likely a timeout
of some kind happened.
So to combat this, we looked
at how resources were actually
being created within the store.
So, any time a user
ended up in a new view,
there were a ton of
requests going out.
So we were requesting
information
on how things are
laid out, images,
getting text, all those things.
Yeah, so, ton of texture,
ton of product art, and we
also had our text.
So, to keep the
frame rates steady,
we decided to basically
pay off the amount
of time over a series of frames.
So to do this, we
created a Task Manager,
because why not have an
operating system construct
in your WebGL program?
So it's not really complicated,
it's just a simple [INAUDIBLE],
[INAUDIBLE] priority,
it wasn't really needed.
So, in our case, what
exactly is a task for us?
So, when image is
received, we actually
defer the loading to
the animation frame.
So we get the response, we
say, OK, you are our task,
I'm going to insert
you to the queue,
and you are going to run
at some time in the future.
So, we also did text
creation that way.
Our text creation could
probably be a bit better,
there's certainly
some optimizations
we could do there, like a
bitmap font or things like that.
But, due to the amount of
time of me going nuclear,
didn't really have
time for that.
So we actually used Canvas.
And whenever we request
a new batch of text,
it actually busts it
up into three steps.
So initially we compute
the layout, from there,
we take that and draw
it into the canvas.
And then, another task comes
around and actually uploads
the canvas to a texture.
Those last two end up
being slotted right next
to each other, so
didn't really have
to worry about
anything in there.
So, to keep our
frame rates steady,
we needed to limit the
amount of time we actually
took to run these tasks.
So, that pretty much
ensures the application has
enough time for anything
else it wants to do.
Like an update in
renderer and all that.
So obviously, it's not
a perfect solution,
because there is
essentially no way
to stop a task
once it's started.
When you upload a
texture, it's going
to take however long
it's going to take.
And that's it.
So if you had the case where you
set something for, let's say,
five milliseconds, and you had
your task finished at four,
it's going to kick
off another one,
and if that one goes another
five milliseconds, really
not much you can do.
So really, at this point, to
do that, we more or less played
with the numbers and
figured out exactly
what felt good in terms
of the frame rate,
versus how quickly the
assets were appearing.
So if you made it super quick,
you're always going to get 60,
but, things are going
to creep in slower.
So it's definitely a
balancing game there.
So, obviously, our task manager,
nothing special, first in,
first out.
We look at the number
of tasks, we compare it
to whatever our maximum
time span is, we pop a task,
we run it, we check
it, and we keep
going until we either run out
of tasks or we run out of time.
So, like I said,
nothing special,
but it actually really helped
us keep that frame rate.
So, in conclusion
here, if you want
to optimize a WebGL application,
you need to do the following.
You need to ensure you renderer
is optimal by preventing
redundant calls,
you need to optimize
how geometry is submitted
to your application.
And really to avoid
any sort of jank,
you need to keep the work
on the animation frame.
So if you follow
these rules, you'll
be able to really push your
application even further,
and create even more compelling,
awesome experiences with WebGL.
So, now we are in the shameless
self-promotion portion
of the talk, so
this particular talk
is more or less a PS4-themed
version of an article
wrote for "HTML5 Game
Development Insights,"
currently available for
pre-order on Apress.
And it has a lot of great
input from other devs,
and the pirate guy helped
out, as I'm sure you've seen.
AUDIENCE: Oh, kill your crew.
DON OLMSTEAD: Yes,
kill your crew.
All right, so, any
questions we're
deferring to the QA panel.
But here's obviously my
contact info on the right.
I'm pretty good with g+, I also
go to various other speaking
gigs, like speaking at the
DartSF meet up next month,
because Dart is awesome.
And of course,
SNEI is hiring, we
have a booth here, we
have a PlayStation 4,
and obviously, if you're a
web dev, one of the things
that really sucks
about web dev, is
worrying about older browsers.
And we don't really have that,
since we own the browser,
so you're never
really going to have
to worry about IE8 or
anything like that.
So, definitely thank
you guys for having me.